house speaker nancy pelosi and senate
minority leader chuck schumer are
calling for president trump to be
removed from office
they want vice president pence and the
cabinet to invoke the 25th amendment
nancy cordes is on capitol hill nancy
what's the latest on that well anthony
democrats are pushing the president's
now dwindling cabinet to swiftly invoke
the 25th amendment declaring him
unfit for office replacing him with vice
president mike pence for the final 12
days
of his term but so far they've gotten no
formal response from the cabinet
the vp won't take their calls and so now
they're working on a plan b
this is urgent this is emergency of the
highest
magnitude calling president trump
dangerous house speaker nancy pelosi
declared he should be removed
following this week's insurrection at
the capitol
democrats plan to talk today about a
backup plan
if the 25th amendment isn't invoked the
next best thing is impeachment asap
and it wasn't just democrats illinois
republican adam kinzinger it's time to
invoke the 25th amendment
and to end this nightmare all
indications are that the president has
become unmoored
not just from his duty nor even as of
but from reality
itself other republicans like senator
marco rubio called out their own gop
colleagues saying they misled supporters
by suggesting that the election results
could be overturned criminals are
responsible for their own conduct
senator ted cruz rejected that
accusation
though he did find fault with the
president i think
his his angry rhetoric was was reckless
and i think it was harmful
but not harmful enough allies say to
warrant
removal i don't support an effort to
invoke the 25th amendment
now south carolina's lindsey graham has
spent
more time with mr trump than nearly any
other lawmaker do you believe
after spending so much time with him
that he is mentally unwell
as some of his aides have said i think
he's very frustrated he thinks the
election were stolen
i think he's uh got some very bad
advisors in wilmington delaware
president-elect joe biden argued the
advisors
are not the main problem he unleashed
an all-out assault on our institutions
of our democracy from the outset
and yesterday was what the culmination
of that unrelenting attack
speaker pelosi is holding a conference
call with house democrats at noon to
gauge their interest
in impeachment they could skip the
committee process go straight to a vote
on the house floor but then the senate
would have to hold a trial
and congress is out right now not
expected to return gail
until january 20th inauguration day
that really cuts into the timeline
doesn't it thank you very much nancy